Oh Roxy you're on the air okay hi dr.
Wallach yes how can I help you
yes I think you can help me I have two
grandchildren my daughter and they're
both boys and they both have autism and
I can't hold her they 1 is 8 and the
other one is almost 6 okay and I know
their weights also okay what's the
weight yeah the older one the eight or
nine year old he weighs 75 pounds mm-hmm
he's 52 inches tall and the younger one
where he's 50 pounds he's 45 inches tall
okay well here's the thing we want to do
number one I'd get them both on the
Healthy Start pack appropriate for their
body weight the 75 pound guy he can take
one Healthy Start pack per month give
him a half a dose of breakfast half a
dose of dinner the little guy went fifty
pounds he can take half of the Healthy
Start pack each month so one Healthy
Start packs gonna last him two months
and so you're gonna give him a half of
those each day but cut that half of
those and a half so you getting your
quarter of a dose of breakfast quarter
with those two dinner so the last team
two months for the 50 pound kid and the
75 pound guy give him a half a dose of
breakfast half a toast at dinner I'd
also have them have eggs for breakfast
scrambled eggs and butter kids tend to
like scrambled eggs and butter you can
salt them and all that kind of stuff you
have hamburger patties not the button no
sugar I would also make ice cream out of
our again shake throw some eggs in there
our slender effect shake make it with a
heavy whipping cream there's no sugar in
it you got to stay away from shorter
that includes fruit and fruit juices
they get everything they need from
vegetables that they would get from
fruit without the sugar piece and then
it would also give the little guy the
50-pound guide to of our D stress
capsules per day the 75-pound guy give
him four day to breakfast to a dinner if
they don't want to swallow them you can
open them up and give you know put the
powder in a tablespoon of unsweetened
applesauce and let's start there let's
start there getting off of all gluten no
wheat brother our oats I'd get them that
serial-killer
CD we also have one called God's recipe
which goes into adda th
you knowit ISM and then it wouldn't hurt
for the mother your daughter to get in
addition to the CD called serial killers
and you find of course wheat and
everything they used it taken in tomato
soup these are this filler and things
like meatloaf and meatballs it's also a
filler and sauces like meats Rami
pepperoni salami Bologna and cetera et
cetera all that's gonna be done but let
her get the book rares benchers and read
chapters four or five and six will be
very revealing
[Music]